[Music]
how and when did our universe begin how
did it get to look like this how will it
end humans have been discussing these
questions for as long as they've been
around without ever reaching much
agreement today cosmologists are working
hard to find the answers but how can
anyone hope to find concrete answers to
such profound questions and how is it
possible to explore and study something
as huge as the universe most of which
we'll never be able to reach the answer
is light and although light from distant
parts of the universe can take billions
of years to reach us
it carries six unique messages that when
put together can disclose an amazing
amount of information to astronomers who
know how to look for it just as sunlight
can be split up into the familiar
rainbow splitting the light from distant
objects exposes different patterns of
colors depending on its source this
distinctive light barcode can reveal not
only an object's composition but also
the temperature and pressure of its
constituent parts there's even more we
can discover from light
if you've ever stood on a train platform
you might have noticed that the train
sounds different depending on its
direction with
sending what it approaches you
and descending when it speeds away but
this isn't because the train conductor
is practicing for a second career rather
it's because of something called the
Doppler effect where sound waves
generated by an approaching object are
compressed while those from a receding
object are stretched but what is this to
do with astronomy sound does not travel
through a vacuum in space no one can
hear you scream but the same Doppler
effect applies to light whose source is
moving at exceptional speed if it's
moving towards us the shorter wavelength
will make the light appear to be bluer
while light from a source that's moving
away will have a longer wavelength
shifting towards red so by analyzing the
color pattern and the Doppler shift of
the light from any object observed with
a telescope we can learn what it's made
of how hot it is and how much pressure
it's under as well as whether it's
moving in what direction and how fast
and these six measurements like six
points of light reveal the history of
the universe the first person to study
the light from distant galaxies was
Edwin Hubble and the light he observed
was red shifted the distant galaxies
were all moving away from us and the
further away they were the faster they
were receding Hubble had discovered our
universe is expanding providing the
first evidence for the big bang theory
along with the idea that the visible
universe has been constantly expanding
from a densely packed single point one
of these theories most important
predictions is that the early universe
consisted of just two gases hydrogen and
helium in a ratio of 3 to 1 and this
prediction can also be tested with light
if we observe the light from a remote
quiet region of the universe and split
it we do indeed find the signatures of
the two gases in just those proportions
another triumph for the Big Bang
however many puzzles remain although we
know the visible universe is expanding
gravity should be applying the brakes
but recent measurements of light distant
dying stars show us that they're farther
away than predicted so the expansion of
the universe is actually accelerating
something appears to be pushing it and
many scientists believe that something
is dark energy making up over two-thirds
of the universe and slowly tearing it
apart our knowledge of the behavior of
matter and the precision of our
instruments means that simply observing
distant stars can tell us more about the
universe than we ever thought possible
but there are other mysteries like the
nature of dark energy upon which we have
yet to shed light
Oh
[Music]